Rappel Xinhà mùi giới chiếm mời và là ứng cờ viên thuộc tướng của Đảng Rastia, Swang Tantra,
Việt tắp Laura, SP đang nổi lên như gương mặt có thể dành quyền lạnh đạo nơi bán khi kết quả kiểm tiêu bán đầu trong thảy đảng của ông,
đang rất đầu trong cuộc tầm tuyên cờ. Ông xa tình nổi tiếng trong lòng nhạc Rapp nơi bán trước khi bước tranh bảo chính trường,
năm hàng nghỉ khu trọng 2.2, ông dành chiếc thảm bất ngờ trong cuộc bầu cờ thì trường thành phố thu đồ các mặt đủ của nơi bán bà sau đó xây dân thình gài một chiến trị ra trẻ.
Tụ hút xử ủng hộ mạnh mẽ của giới chiến ấy và dân dễ trong chiếc chiến cơ của mình ông xa cảm kết tăng cờng và trò của thành nghiên trong quả chi cú ra,
lấy mạnh tưởng dụng công nghệ trong cuộc mạnh nhà nước và mời có chuyện ra độ b辣 tham gia hạt định chính sách.
Chếc chiến cơ của ông được đảng chủ quan RRSP, điều phối tập trong tư tru sở tại thành phố cám hành đủng vời hàng trăm nữ sử và đúng mu chuyển thông sấu lớn.
Lông thời gian đuồn tài trợ nắng kể từ góc đồng người nét vào nữ ngoài.
Cô tổng tình cờ nếp ăn kết túc này của năm tham và đang trong dài đoạn kết biểu.
Sự kiện dễn ra trong khoảng nửa nâm sau là sống biểu tình gió dưới chè khởi sường bất cả chiến nâm ngoài.
Khiến cự thủ tưởng xa mà ui phải tuy trước, là sống trên á mạnh lái sau đó của kết cận tảm người trên mạm.
Theo ý bán đầu cờ nếp ăn kết quả của cùng của cuộc tổng tình cờ sẽ được công bố trong cận tư rí.